ومعنا الان من العاصمه القطريه الدوحه
الدكتور خليل الحيا نائب رئيس حركه حماس
في غزه ومسؤول مكتب العلاقات العربيه
والاسلاميه في الحركات دكتور خليل اهلا بك
والسؤال الذي ابدا به هل انتم مستعدون
لحرب تطول اشهر اذا ما قررت اسرائيل ذلك
كما
تقول بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولمشاهده فضائيه الجزيره تحيه لشعبنا
الصامد المرابط تحيه لمقاومتها الباسله
الت التي اي تواجهوا قوات العدو الغازيه
بكل بكل بساله نحن اختي العزيزه كشعب
فلسطيني و كمقاوم فلسطينيه نظرنا انفسنا
للدفاع عن شعبنا وعن حقوقه الاصيله
المشروعه وهذه الحرب المجنونه التي يشنها
الاحتلال ومعه قوى الظلم والاستكبار وفي
مقدمه مهم امريكا الشريك والمشارك في هذه
الحرب المسعوره على شعبنا في قطاع غزه ان
دل على شيء حتى اليوم بعد اكثر من 70 يوما
ومقاومتنا الباسله تصد العدوان وتكبد
العدو خسائر في المعدات والافراد التي
يتخفى الاحتلال الصهيوني على اظهارها خوفا
من انهيارات في مجتمعه الصهيوني وحكومته
الفاشيه يدل دلاله قاطعه على ان المقاومه
صامده
ومستمره وقادره وهي قادره على تكبيد العدو
خسائر اكثر مما يتوقع وما كل يوم وانتم
تعلنون الاحصائيات من جنود وقاده العدو
وضباطه والياته العسكريه والكمائن المحكمه
لكتائب القسام وللمقاومة
وكل
اي الخزي والعار ي جلله لذلك المقاومه
صامده وباسه وقادره على مواص الدفاع عن
شعبنا وانا اقول بكل وضوح ان مقاومتنا وفي
مقدمتها كتائب القسام قادره على الصمود
امام الاحتلال وعدوانه اكثر من قدره
الاحتلال على بطشه وعدوانه وان احتمى بكل
التته العسكريه الاجراميه ولكن دكتور خليل
هل من مبادرات جديده بخصوص تبادل
الاسرى نحن ما يهمنا بالدرجه الاساسيه كيف
كيف نحمي شعبا هذا الشعب العظيم المرابط
الذي له 75 عاما يان تحت الاحتلال ويقتل
بالتدريج اليوم يقتل على مراه ومسمع
العالم بالجمله ولذلك المبادرات
التي تطلق هنا وهناك نحن قلنا بكل وضوح
يقف العدوان يقف هذا العدوان المجنون
والقتل على شعبنا وتدمير المقدرات
والانسان وتجريف الاحياء
بالجرافات العملاقه ليقف هذا العدوان وكل
شيء بعد ذلك يمكن الحديث عنه وفي مقدمه
ذلك تبادل الاسرى واغاثه شعبنا الفلسطيني
ولذلك عندما راينا ان الاحتلال يتلاعب
بهذه الورقه ورقه بين مزدوجين اي
المحتجزين او المخطوفين او ما يطلق يطلقون
عليه الرهائن هذا الورقه الاحتلال
الصهيوني هو يتلاعب بها وما قتله بالامس
ثلاثه من جنوده وهم يرفعون الرايه البيضاء
ويتحدثون بالعبريه ويقولوا اغيثو الا
دلاله عن هذه الورقه لا
اي يعيرها نتنياهو وحكومته الفاشيه اي
اعتبار انما يستخدمها استخداما لاطاله امد
الحرب لذلك قلنا بكل وضوح ونؤكد اليوم على
شاشه الجزيره ان ملف التبادل هذا مغلق حتى
يقف العدو الوان فاذا ما توقف العدوان
فنحن جاهزون فورا للبدء في مفاوضات لتبادل
الاسرى بشكل كامل و ويمكن ان نحدد سقفا
زمنيا لذلك يتزامن هذا مع اغاثه شعبنا من
الايواء والاعمار وادخال كل المساعدات
اللازمه لشعبنا الفلسطيني على طريق نيل
حقوقه المشروع هل هناك اي صيغه جديده يمكن
لحماس ان تطرحها لاتمام عمليه التبادل غير
هذا الموقف بانه يش رد وقف القتال حتى
الخوض حتى في
الموضوع اعتقد ان هذه الصيغه هي التي
تعارف عليها كل العالم على مدار تاريخه
انا لا اعلم ان هناك اي والحرب دائره
والصواريخ تدك في قطاع غزه تدك العظام
واللحم والاحياء من النساء والاطفال
والمساجد والمستشفيات والمدارس وبيوت
الايواء لا يعقل ان ان نعقد حوار مع هذا
العدو المجرم تحت النار لا يمكن ان نعقد
صفقه صفقه تبادل اسرى تحت هذه النيران
ليقف العدوان اولا وينسحب الاحتلال من
قطاع غزه وندخل مباشره في تبادل اسرى ونح
ونضع له سقفا زمنيا اما غير ذلك باعتقاد
انه مضي على الوقت وملها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالمناسبه يستخدم هذه الورقه
لتهدئه خواطر عائله المختطفين في داخل
الكيان صهيوني لانه يريد ان يعني يتلاعب
بهذه الورقه ويقول توجد مبادرات وتوجد
مفاوضات وانا اؤكد نحن اغلقنا هذا الباب
من اسبوعين وابلغنا الوسطاء بشكل واضح ان
هذه الورقه اغلقت ولا تفتح الا عند وقف
اطلاق النار ووقف العدوان وهو الوقت
المناسب والظرف الم الملائم لشعبنا
وللمفوضية
يمكن ان يظن انه يمكن ان نستجيب تحت الضغط
فهو واهم وهو يعلم ان حماس عصيه على
الاستجابه تحت الضغط نحن ن يعني نحمل
بندقيته ونقاتل الاحتلال دفاعا عن شعبنا
وما يهمنا هؤلاء الالاف مئات الالاف
المشردين والمعذبين الذين سقط العالم سقط
العالم سقوطا مدويا ان يغيثه تحت جبروت
الاحتلال العالم اليوم للاسف شديد يسقط
سقوطا مروعا وهو لا يستطيع ان يغيث شعبا
بكامله 2 مليون فلسطيني لا يستطيع العالم
ان يلزم الاحتلال ان يدخل الهم الماء
والغذاء والدواء هذا العالم لا يستطيع ان
يلزم الاحتلال بكل ال التته الاجراميه ان
يوصل لهم ما يطلبون ويتباكون انهم يدخلون
في معبر رفح صحيح 100 شاحنه محمله بالماء
وال والدواء والغذاء وغيره ماذا تنفع 100
شاحنه لا 2 مليون ربع فلسطيني يعيشون في
غزه لهم اكثر من 70 يوم لم يدخل لهم شيء
الا اذا سمحت دكتور خليل ساعود للموضوع
الانساني والوضع الانساني للغزيين ولكن
اريد ان اسالك عن توصيف للوضع الميداني
حاليا في محاور
القتال اولا اسمحي اقول لك انه بكل بكل
اعتزاز وبكل فخر نوجه التحيه لمقاتلين
ومجاهدينا في كتائب القسام وفي كل فصائل
المقاومه الذين يلاحقون العدو من شارع الى
شارع ومن منطقه الى منطقه ومن زقاق الى
زقاق فالعدو لا يهنا لا لا في لا في غزه
ولا في خانيونس ولا في الشمال ولا في
الشجاعيه ولا في جباليا ولا في جحر الديك
ولا في خانيونس ولا في اي منطقه من الاما
الاماكن مقاومون ومجاهدو يلاحقون العدو
يتربصون به في كل مكان يضربون هذه الدبابه
وهذه الاليه يلاحقونه يلاحقون جنوده
مقاتلون لا يتخفون مقاتلون لا يهربون
مقاتلون يواجهون من نقطه الصفر هذا العدو
ليذيقهم من كاس الموت الذي يذيقه لشعبنا
الاعزل بعبر ق طائراته لذلك المعارك
والمواجهات مستعره على كل المناطق
والجبهات
المقاومه صامده وباسه ولديها الامكانات
للاستمرار ايام واسابيع وشهور
وليعد علينا العالم ايام واسابيع وشهور
وستلقي مقاومتنا هذا العدو دروسا من الموت
ودروسا من تحميل جنوده وضباطه قتلا من من
قلب غزه حتى يرعوي فنحن شعب يقاتل من اجل
عداله قضيته وحريه شعبه وهذا يمكن ان ندفع
له كل الاثمان وندفع له كل المهج والارواح
التي دفعناها من خيره ابنائنا وقادتنا
لذلك نحن نطمئن شعبنا ونطمئن امتنا ان
المقاومه صامده وبخير وتذيع الاحتلال في
كل يوم انتم تتح نحن نتحدث عن بعد اكثر من
70 يوم والاحتلال بكل الياته لم يستطع ان
ان ياخذ صوره نصر مزيفه صوره نصر مزيفه
الا هذا الدمار الذي الحقه بالبنيه
المدنيه من عمارات وشوارع وبنيه تحتيه اما
المقاومه فهي التي تخرج له من مكان الى
اخر وتقتنص الفرصه لقتله في الياته او
قتله في مهاجع او قتله هنا وهناك ولذلك
نحن بكل اعتزاز نعتز بمقاومتها التي
بصمودها وصمود شعبنا الذي لن يرفع الرايه
وسيبقى صامدا على ارضه محتضنا مقاومته
التي تنتمي اليه ويحتضنه هذا الشعب قادرون
على تحقيق حقوقنا باذن الله عز وجل فكل
المحاور اختي الكريمه كل المحاور من
الشمال الى الجنوب المقاومه بخير تخرج من
للاحتلال من كل مكان هنا وهناك والاحتلال
لا يعرف من اين يتلقى الضربات نعم نحن
نواجه عدوا شرسا عدوا يمتلك الطائرات
لكننا نمتلك الاراده عدوا يمتلك الدبابات
لكننا نمتلك المقاتل صاحب العقيده القويه
وصاحب
الاراده الجباره وصاحب القدره والبراعه في
اقتناه عدو
لذلك هذه ارضنا وهذا ميداننا الذي اعددنا
فيه ابناؤنا
وقادتنا ليواجهوا هذا العدوان حتى التحرير
والعوده اننا نرنو ونحن في طوفان القدس
وليعلم كل العالم اننا ننظر ونحن في طوفان
القدس من بنادق مقاتلينا ومن فوهه الياسين
ومن ح ومن تدمير هذه الاليات ننظر الى قبه
الصخره والمسجد الاقصى لانه عنوان المعركه
اننا لن يردنا على الدفاع عن شعبنا
ومواجهه هذا العدوان الا تحرير الارض
وعوده الانسان الى ارضه التي سلبت منه هذه
عزيمتنا وهذا قرارنا وهذا عمل الذي نسعى
له دكتور اريد ان اعود للموقف بالنسبه
للتفاوض فيما ذكرته الربط بتوقف القتال
ونريد ان نعرف المعني تحديدا بوقف القتال
هل هو هدنه ام اتفاق سياسي كذلك وقف اطلاق
النار هل المقصود وقف متبادل ام رؤيه
سياسيه شامله ما
المقصود نحن نتحدث بشكل واضح
اي على
اننا نريد حقيقه ان نوقف العدوان اولا ما
يهمنا اليوم هو وقف هذا العدوان وهذه
الحرب المجنونه نريد ان نوقف عدوان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على المسجد الاقصى
الذي عنوان المعركه ما الذي حرك
كتائب القسام والمقاومه ليقوموا بطوفان
الاقصى الا ما يتعرض له الاقصى ولذلك نحن
نقول يوم نريد وقف العدوان شاملا وقف
اطلاق النار في غزه المتبادل بيننا وبين
الاحتلال وتخرج د وتخرج كل القوات قوات
الاحتلال من قطاع غزه وان مباشره نفتح ملف
التفاوض جنبا الى جنب يسير مع اغاثه غزه
بكل ما تحتاجه واغاثه غزه من الايواء
والغذائي والدوائي واعاده الاعمار ما دمر
احتلال من بنيه تحتيه وغير ذلك وصولا الى
اننا نريد بكل وضوح وحده لشعبنا وحده
لشعبنا فغزا والضفه وحده واحده لا تنفك عن
بعضها وشعبنا الفلسطين نقول نقول بكل وضوح
من يفكر في اليوم التالي لغزه فاليوم
التالي لغزه هو انتصار ومن يفكر ما بعد
حماس فهو ينتظر الوهم وطول الامد ان شعبنا
الفلسطيني هو الوحيد المكلف الذي هو الذي
يختار قيادته وهو الذي يختار الاليه التي
يدير بها شؤونه ونحن لا نقبل تدخلا لا من
هنا ولا من هناك نحن شعب شب على الطوق
وعنده الاراده والقدره لان يختار قيادته
بارادته عبر صناديق الاقتراع او عبر
التوافق المؤقت حتى نصل الى صناديق
الاقتراع اذا نحن نتحدث بشكل وضوح نحن
نريد وقف العدوان
ونذهب مباشره الى الاعمار والايواء
وجنبا الى جنب الى التفاوض على الاسرى حتى
ننهي هذه القضيه هذا هو المسار الذي نؤمن
به تحدثنا به مطولا من اليوم الاول لهذا
العدوان ونحن نكرره عبر قناه الجزيره الان
لانه ليس جديدا انما قلناه عبر الايام
الماضيه ونكرره اليوم نريد وقف العدوان
كاملا وانسحاب القوات ووقف العدوان على
المسجد الاقصى وايضا
الت تبادل الاسرى واغاثه شعبنا بكل ما
يحتاجه من الغذاء والدواء والكساء واعاده
الاعمار هذه ما نقوله وقلناه ونكده اليوم
من جديد دكتور خليل اريد ان اذكر لك ما
قاله منسق السياسات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي جون كيري عندما سئل لماذا لا
تتحرك واشنطن لوقف قتل المدنيين
الفلسطينيين ومواصلتها الدعم اسرائيل دون
قيود
اجاب اسالوا حماس عن دائره العنف من بدا
هذه الحرب هو من خرق التهدئه التي كانت
قائمه ما
ردكم اولا على
هذا ان يتذكر اولا ان الشعب الفلسطيني له
محتل 75 سنه وان الشعب
الفلسطيني امام هذه الحكومه الفاشيه
الاسرائيليه هو من سعر نار هذا الطوفان من
الذي اطلق
يد اسمه رتش الى الى الاستيطان واكل الضفه
الغربيه والاستيطان من الذي اطلق يد ابن
غفير لان يقول اليوم انا احيي الجندي
الاسرائيلي الذي دنس المسجد احد مساجد
جنين وتكلم بالعبريه وتكلم بوراه من داخل
المسجد في جنين هذه الحكومه الفاشيه التي
قررت السيطره على المسجد الاقصى ودنست
اياما ومرارا وعبر اعيادهم التي قاموا
فيها اعمال لم يفعلوها من س من 75 سنه من
الذي فعل ذلك من الذي وضع خارطه فلسطين في
فرنسا وقال لا يوجد شعب فلسطيني من الذي
قال خارطه اسرائيل فلسطين والاردن
والجولان وجزء من الاراضي العربيه الاخرى
من الذي قال ذلك من الذي عصف بالقضيه
الفلسطينيه ولذلك هذا الطوفان الاقصى جاء
ردا على الاستهتار بالشعب الفلسطيني
وعلى زاره الظهر للحقوق المشروعه للشعب
الفلسطيني وعلى تدنيس المسجد الاقصى وعلى
الاستيطان وعلى ال التلاعب بقضيه الاسرى
وتعذيبهم وعلى استمرار حصار غزه هذه هي
الاسباب المباشره التي جعلت طوفان الاقصى
يقول للعالم الشعب الفلسطيني حي والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه باقيه قادره على ان تقول
للعالم هنا فلسطين وهذا الشعب الفلسطيني
يريد حقه ولا يقبل الضيم ولا يقبل ان ان
تصفى قضيته هذا عليه كان ان يتذكر ذلك كان
عليه ان يتذكر ما قاله بايدن يوم الايام
لابو مازن عندما قال نريد حل الدولتين
فقال عندما ينزل المسيح هؤلاء الذين
اداروا الظهر للقضيه الفلسطينيه وللشعب
الفلسطيني طب وان اقول اذا كنا في غزه في
طوفان الاقصى قلنا نريد ان ان نقول للعالم
نحن هنا شعب يريد قضيته وندافع عن الاقصى
فماذا يحدث في الضفه الغربيه يا اختي
الكريمه الضفه الغربيه اليوم التي يقصفها
الاحتلال بالطائرات ويجرف منازلها وبيوتها
ومقدراتها بالجرافات كل ذلك نحن كشعب
فلسطيني اليوم امام هجوم بربري قاتل
اجرامي
بشع نازي ضد شعبنا الفلسطيني في كل مكان
فلم يسلم من الشعب الفلسطيني احد لا غزه
ولا الضفه ولا القدس ولا حتى 48 الذين وضع
الاحتلال على طائله الاستهداف والتهجير هل
من تواصل بينكم وبين السلطه الفلسطينيه
بشان ما يجري في الضفه او بشان ما يجري في
غزه والمستقبل بشكل
عام نحن الهدف الاساسي اليوم واجب الوقت
اختي الكريمه على وقف العدوان نحن كل
اتصالاتنا مع كل الاطراف كيف نوقف العدوان
على الشعب الفلسطيني في غزه وكيف نغيث
هؤلاء اللاجئون المحرومون الذين يتضورون
جوعا هذا هو الواجب الذي نتحدث به مع كل
العالم وهنا نؤكده اليوم نحن هذا ما
يشغلنا الان في كل علاقاتنا وحديثنا مع كل
الاطراف اطراف كثيره تتحدث عن مستقبل غزه
انتم في حماس كيف ترون هذا المستقبل اعرف
انك المحت اليه ولكن اريد مختصر مفيد لو
سمحت
غزه والضفه وكل فلسطين وحده
واحده من يقرر الشان الفلسطيني في غزه
والضفه هو الشعب الفلسطيني والقياده التي
يرتضيها الشعب الفلسطيني ولذلك نحن نطمن
العالم اوقفوا العدوان ونحن ندير امورنا
بانفسنا وحماس هي جزء اصيل من هذا الشعب
الفلسطيني نحن قلنا مرارا وتكرارا نحن جزء
من هذا الشعب نلتحق به والتحف بنا نحن من
يدير هذا الشعب كجزء من قياده هذا الشعب
الفلسطيني نريد ان نجدد هذه القياده عبر
الانتخابات لكن الان واجب الوقت وقف
العدوان اما غزه فهي جزء من الوطن الكبير
وجزء من الوطن الصغير الضفه الغربيه وقطاع
غزه ولذلك اليوم نحن نقول مص مستقبل غزه
هو مرتبط بمستقبل القدس هو مرتبط بمستقبل
الضفه الغربيه هو مستقبل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين في في مناحي العالم غزه
مرتبطه بفلسطين وفلسطين مرتبطه ب غزه ولا
انفكاك
بينه نعود الان للوضع الانساني الوضع
الانساني يزداد صعوبه في غزه هذا اقل ما
يمكن قوله ما الذي يمكن لحماس فعله
للغزيين في هذه الظروف الصعبه والقاسيه
جدا نحن يعني في حماس اولا نحن جزء من هذا
الشعب ونحن نجوع كما يجوع
ونعرات واهلنا وذو ملتحف بهذا الشعب وهم
جزء منه لكن نحن كحركه نطرق كل الابواب
ونتصل مع كل الاطراف على زياده الاغاثه
وعلى ادخال الاغاثه والمعونات
وزيادتها فلا يعقل حتى الان ان يدخل فقط
من معبر رفح 100 شاحنه او اليوم قالوا 120
او 130 او 150 لا يعقل لذلك احنا املنا في
امتنا العربيه والاسلاميه املنا في الدول
العربيه التي نقدرها ونحترمها ان تضغط على
كل الاطراف وفي مقدمتهم امريكا التي هي
التي تضع هذا الاطار العام لهذه المساعدات
مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان الاحت ان غزه
تحتاج في اليوم الى مئات الشاحنات لتغيظ
هذا الشعب لذلك الشعب اليوم تحت وقع
الامطار والشتاء القارص بلا طعام ولا شراب
ولا غذا وانتم تلاحظون ولذلك ما نفعله
اننا ندق ونطرق ونتصل مع كل الناس لاغاثه
شعبنا الفلسطيني وما نستطيع تقديمه
حتى داخل غزه اما من خلال المساعدات
ونساعد بقدر ما نستطيع بل واذا هناك شيء
نشتريه من غزه من من التجار وغير ذلك نحن
نقدمه للناس بكل حب وبكل اريحيه ولذلك
اهلنا
واخواننا وشبابنا منتشرون في كل الاماكن
ليقدموا ما يستطيعون ويشتروا ما يستطيعون
ويق يمونه للناس لكن المهم اختي الكريمه
ان غزه لم يعد فيها شيء
يشترى ومعبر رفح على ما يفتح لكنه قاصر
على ان ايصال المطلوب لاهل غزه ولذلك انا
اعتقد انه بمقدور الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه والعالم والاسره الدوليه ان
تجبر هذا الاحتلال ان يدخل غزه كل ما
تحتاجه والادهى والامر نحن نتحدث يعني
شمال القطاع وجنوبه شمال القطاع نحن نتحدث
عن 600000 موا ما زالوا موجودين في قطاع
غزه بالارقام يعني في مدينه غزه ما يقرب
من ربع مليون مواطن موجود وفي الشمال ما
يقرب من 350 الف مواطن موجودون في بيوت
الاواء وفي بيوتهم والاحتلال يحاول ان
يشرده بكل الاليات ويضرب كل معاني التواجد
ان كان من مستشفيات او بيوت ايواء وغير
ذلك ومن هنا
نحن نطالب بحقنا ك كبشر و وحقنا على
الانسانيه وحقنا على العروبه والاسلام ان
تغيث هذا الش
وبمقدوره نحن نقول ان بمقدور هذه الدول ان
تتضافر وان تضغط على الاحتلال وان تدخل كل
هذه المساعدات هل يعقل لهذه الامه العظيمه
العربيه والاسلاميه ان تبقى اسيره لقرار
الاحتلال القاتل المجرم الذي يضرب هذا
الشعب الله شعبنا وانتم تسمعون عبر شاشتكم
ان الصرخات التي
تصرخ النساء والاطفال والرجال وهم
يستغيثون بهذه الامه نحن نق قدر للامه
اليوم تضامنها معنا ان كان عسكريا او كان
مدنيا للضغط على هذا الاحتلال لكن نحن
نريد في الوضع الانساني الا يبقى هذا
الشعب لان اقول اي الاخت الكريمه اقول ان
الاحتلال اليوم يضرب غزه بسلاحين السلاح
الاول سلاح
فتاك له خط مباشر من امريكا بالقنابل
والصواريخ بعشرات الاف الاطنان التي تسقط
على على رؤوس الناس وهم احياء والسلاح
الاكثر فتكا هو سلاح الجوع سلاح الجوع هل
تعلمين ان هناك بيوت في غزه اليوم لهم
ايام لم يجدون شربه ماء شربه ماء
والاحتلال المجرم هل تعلمين انه بطائراته
يقصف كل خزانات المياه على الموجوده على
ظهور الاماكن حتى لا لا تحافظ على الماء
يطلق الرصاص عليه مباشره من طائرات الكوات
كابتر او غيرها حتى لا يبقي مظاهر للحياه
فانا اقول امام هذه الماساه التي يعيش
شعبنا قادر على الحياه ومصمم على الحياه
لكن الحياه تحتاج الى متطلبات هل يعقل ان
اليوم وهذا احد الفشل في الهدنه السابقه
عندما لم نستطع ادخال الى شمال القطاع عبر
اسبوع كامل الا 300 شاحنه جزء منها ماء
وغير ذلك ولذلك نحن نقول اليوم هذا مطلبنا
وحقنا على الامه ان غيث هذا الشعب بما
يلزمه من الدواء والغذاء والكساء وكل شيء
طيب يعني هل هناك مثلا مبادرات انسانيه
سياسيه تسمح بدخول هذه
المتطلبات في
القريب نحن نسمع عن يعني حراك على زياده
عدد الشاحنات التي ستمر عبر معبر رفح
واستمعنا انه من اليوم ستدخل عبر كرم ابو
سالم وهذا يمكن يمكن ان يسهل العمليه
وهناك يبدو ان امريكا استيقظت مؤخرا على
الضغط الجماهيري الذي اصبح يجوب عواصم
العالم وقلب العاصمه الامريكيه امام هذه
الماساه الانسانيه ويبدو انها ضغطت على
الاحتلال بطريقه ما ان يزيد من حجم ال
المعونات والاغاثه التي تدخل قطاع غزه نحن
نامل ذلك اي هناك مبادرات المهم ان الكل
يقف عاجزا عن ارغام الاحتلال بادخال
اكثر من المحدد من من الشاحنات نحن نريد
يوميا ان يدخل الى غزه اكثر من 500 شاحنه
محمله بالغذاء والدواء والكساء وغير ذلك
والخي وكل المتطلبات لهذا الشعب حتى يعني
يستطيع ان يصمد وان وان يواجه العدوان
ولذلك نحن نسمع من هنا وهناك هناك بعض
الليونه في الموقف الامريكي هناك بعض
الضغط على الموقف الامريكي الموقف
الامريكي وصل لمرحله انه لم يستطع ان
يتحمل هذه الماساه الانسانيه هكذا يقولون
ونحن نامل ان ان يترجم ذلك على ارض الواقع
افعالا حقيقيه لا مجرد اقوال طيب اسمح لي
ان اسالك سؤالا اخيرا وهو يتعلق بالتصعيد
في البحر الاحمر من جانب انصار الله
الحوثيين الذين يستهدفون اي سفينه تتجه
نحو اسرائيل
وكذلك تصعيد في الجبهه الشماليه من جانب
حزب بالله ما هو تعليقكم على هذا ان اسمح
لي اولا ان اوجه التحيه لكل الامه ولكل
شعوب العالم الحر ان كان في اوروبا او او
في غيرها ان كان في البلدان العربيه
والاسلاميه وفي كل اقطار العالم التي تجوب
الشوارع اليوم وبالامس وفي قلبها تندد
بالعدوان الصهيوني وتندد بالتواطؤ
الامريكي والشراكه الامريكيه في هذا
العدوان ولذلك على امريكا ان تدرك ان
بقائها بجانب الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بدا
يجعل الجماهير في العالم ان تحيط السفارات
الامريكيه بالاعتصام والجماهير وهذا اندل
على شيء فان يدل على حاله الغضب التي بدات
تعتري العالم كله من الموقف الامريكي
المخزي المتواطئ مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هذه من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى انا اوجه
باسم شعبنا التحيه
لاخواننا الانصار الله في اليمن الذين
غيروا معادله حقيقيه
وقالوا لكل العالم اذا لم يتوقف العدوان
على غزه واذا لم تغاث غزه بالطعام والشراب
والدواء فلا طعام ولا سفن تصل الى
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان هذا الموقف المقدر
الذي له ما بعده نقدره عاليا ونشكر
اخواننا انصار الله على هذا الموقف و
ونقول لهم استمروا استمروا واضغطوا على
هذا العالم الذي لا يعرف الا لغه القوه
فلقد فستغربت المشهد والواقع وعلى
الاحتلال وامريكا ان تدرك ان الضغط على
الشعب الفلسطيني واستمرار الضغط سيولد
مفاعيل كبيره ولا انسى ايضا الجبهه
المفتوحه هناك في العراق التي تواجه
المواقع الامريكيه وان دل على شيء فانما
يدل على ان شعوب المنطقه تعرف عدوها وتعرف
من يقتل الشعب الفلسطيني فكل التقدير
والاحترام لاهلنا في العراق الذين يسته
فون المواقع الامريكيه في العراق ليوصلوا
رساله اننا لا نقبل الضغط على الشعب
الفلسطيني وايضا نحن نقدر عاليا جبهه
لبنان المفتوحه التي تشغل هذا العدو ب في
كل يوم وتشغل جيشه
وبوارج الحربيه
وطائراته في دلاله على ان الامه شعوبا
ودولا ومناحي هي شركاء اليوم في هذه
المعركه على طريق كف العدوان ووقف هذه
المعركه المجنونه التي تريد ان تستاصل
القضيه الفلسطينيه وليست هي موجهه لحماس
فقط ونحن نقول لقد نبنى عن الامه في طوفان
الاقصى فعلى الامه اليوم ان تحمي طوفان
الاقصى وتحمي رجالات طوفان الاقصى الذين
حركوا مسار السياسه في هذه المنطقه
واعادوا القضيه الفلسطينيه والقدس الى
واجهه الاحداث دكتور خليل الحيه نائب رئيس
حركه حماس في غزه ومسؤول مكتب العلاقات
العربيه والاسلاميه في الحركه كنت معنا من
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه شكرا
لك شكرا